Here are our solutions.
This middle graph shows p plus q.
The far right one shows p minus q.
And this furthest left one shows q minus p.
Now, this is quite similar to what we did
before, except that this time, as we can
see, both of our original lines have non
zero slope.
Adding the lines happens pretty much the
same way as we did it before.
All of these additions and subtractions.
Cna happen the same way graphically, as
we dealt with them before.
It just feels a little bit more
complicated because our have non zero
slopes.
Adding the two line, works just as it did
before.
And we can see that connecting these
lines gives us, what looks like the
middle graph.
Because we're adding different length
lines to all these different points along
the graph of q.
We're going to end up with a line whose
slope is different from either p or q.
Now, of course, I could have done this
the other way around and drawn lines up
to q and added those to p.
Either way would give us the same result.
We can see, however, that switching the
order of subtraction, changes the graphs
that we get.